[Music]
i'm ashley thomas a cognitive scientist
at the mcgovern institute at mit i use
puppets to study baby minds
and how babies make sense of the world
around them
people used to think that babies didn't
understand much at all about the world
but now we know that's wrong babies
understand a lot
even though babies can't talk their
behavior provides clues about what
they're thinking
babies look at people and things they
like and they focus their attention
where they expect things to happen
so to figure out what a baby is thinking
i measure what they look at
here's what i mean
this is baby ursula she is watching
sarah share food with a puppet
now ursula sees a different person laura
passing a ball with the puppet what
happens if the puppet starts crying who
will comfort the sad puppet sarah or
laura
ursula can't tell us what she is
thinking but she can show us
when ursula looks at sarah first it
tells me that she expects sarah to
comfort the puppet
these types of experiments show us that
babies do understand a lot about the
world around them including complex
social relationships
[Music]